20 years ago you hypothesized that
we would solve the mystery of dark
matter by now
so unfortunately we didn't
yet
first what is dark matter and why has it
been so tough to figure out well i mean
we learned that galaxies and other large
scale structures
which are moving around but
prevent them flying apart by by gravity
um would be flying apart
if they only contain the stuff we see
if everything in them was shining
and to understand how galaxies formed
and why they
do remain confined the same size uh one
has to infer
that there's about five times as much
stuff
producing gravitational forces
than the total amount of stuff in the
gas and stars that we see and that stuff
is called dark matter
um that's his leading name it's not dark
it's just transparent etc um and the uh
most likely interpretation
is that it's a swarm of
microscopic particles
which have no electric charge
and the very small cross sections are
hitting each other and hitting anything
else so they swarm around and we can
detect their collective effects and when
we do computer simulations of how
galaxies form and evolve
and how they emerge from the big bang
then uh we get a nice consistent picture
if we put in
five times as much
mass in the form of these
mysterious dark particles and for
instance it works better if we think
they're non-interacting particles than
if you think they're a gas which would
have shock waves and things so we know
something about the properties of these
but we don't know what they are and um
the disappointment compared to my
guess 20 years ago um is that
particles answering this description
have not yet been found it was thought
that the big accelerator the large
hadron collider at cern which is the
world's biggest might have found a new
class of particles which would have been
the obvious candidates and it hasn't
and
some people say well dark matter can't
be there etc but what i would argue is
that there's a huge amount of
parameter space that hasn't been
explored um there are other kinds of
particles called axions which behave
slightly differently which are a good
candidate um and um there's a factor
over 10 powers of 10
between the heaviest particles that
could be created by
the large hadron collider
and the heaviest particles which on
theoretical grounds could exist
without turning into black holes so
there's a huge amount of uh possible
particles which could be out there
as remnants of the big bang um but which
we wouldn't be able to text so easily so
um the fact that we've got new
constraints on what the dark matter
could be doesn't diminish my belief that
it's there in the form of particles
because we've only explored a small
fraction of parameter space
so there's this search you're
literally
upon unintended are
searching in the dark
here in this giant parameter space of
possible particles you're searching for
i mean there could be all kinds of
particles
it could be and the sum is maybe very
very hard to detect but i think we can
hope for
some new theoretical ideas because um
one point which perhaps you'd like to
discuss more is about the
very early stages of the big bang
and the situation now is that we have a
outline picture for how the universe has
evolved um from
the time it was expanding in just a
nanosecond
right up to the present
and we could do that because
after nanosecond
the physics of the material
is in the same range that we can test in
the lab
after
a nanosecond the particles move around
like those in the last hat or collider
if you wait for one second they're
rather like
in the centers of the hottest stars and
nuclear axes produce hydrogen helium etc
which fit the data so we can with
confidence extrapolate back to when the
universe was not a second old indeed i
think we can do it with as much
confidence as anything a geologist tells
you about the early history of the earth
and that's huge progress in the last 50
years but
any progress puts in sharper focus
new mysteries and of course
the new mysteries in this context are
why is the universe explained the way it
is why does it contain this mixture of
atoms and dark matter and radiation and
why does it have
the properties which allow galaxy to
form
being fairly smooth but not completely
smooth and the answer to those questions
are generally believed to lie in a much
much earlier stage of the universe when
conditions were much more extreme and
therefore far beyond
the stage when we had the foothold and
experiments very theoretical and so um
we don't have a uh convincing theory we
just have ideas until we have something
like string theory or some other clues
to the ultra early universe uh that's
going to remain speculative so um
there's a big gap and to say how big the
gap is um if we take the observable
universe out to
a bit more than 10 billion light years
um then when the universe was a
nanosecond old
that would have been squeezed down to
the size of our solar system
or compressed into that that volume
but
the times we're talking about when the
key properties of the universe were
first imprinted
were times when that entire universe was
squeezed down to the size of a tennis
ball or baseball if you prefer um and it
emerged from something microscopic so
it's a huge extrapolation and it's not
surprising that
since it's so far from our experimental
range of detectability
we are still groping for ideas
but you think first theory will reach
into that place and then experiment will
perhaps one day catch up well i think
simulation in a sense it's a combination
i think
what we hope for
is that um uh there'll be a theory
which applies to the early universe
but which also has consequences which we
can test in our present day universe um
uh like um
discovering my neutrinos exist or things
like that and that's the thing which as
i mentioned we may perhaps need a bit of
ai to help us to calculate but yeah but
i think um the the hope would be
that uh we will have a theory which
applies
under the very very extreme early stages
of the universe but which gains
credibility and gains confidence because
it also manages to account for otherwise
unexplained features of
the low energy world and what people
call a standard model of particle
physics where the lots of undetermined
numbers so it may
help with that
you